and i think it's time once and for all
that we talk about
what it is
to
be a leader and build a big business and
i don't think nice guys finish last and
i don't believe you need sharp elbows
and i don't think it's you got to be
nasty i have no idea why anybody would
verbally dress down an employee in a
conference room with other employees in
there there is no logical [ __ ] sense
whatsoever all right garyvee's here hi
garyvee hi i love seeing you i'm so
happy for you good to see you okay give
us the update in on garyvee's world like
what's happening what are you working on
you've got a new book
there's um always a lot going on i think
right now
trying to balance how intense v friends
my nft project and how explosive the
vayner x holding co
balancing being ceo of two companies of
that size is a new challenge i've done
it before with wine library when i kind
of left my dad's business
it was so emotional was my baby it was
my family business i'd been there
forever and we were just starting
vaynermedia me and aj my brother and so
from 2009 to 2011 i definitely ran both
those businesses but the size of both
those businesses were much smaller than
what i'm dealing with right now
plus it's the moment in web3 meaning
you know there's only these 12 to 36
month windows where the whole industry
is shaping in front of you and there's a
lot of good getting during that time
right investing if you can get in early
timing matters and stuff like that yeah
that's right so just just trying to
balance that i think is really intense
and challenging and exciting um and then
you know what's what's actually being
affected by that because it's really a
lot of time and effort is i'm producing
a hair less content than i have over the
last six years do your fans notice it
i'm not sure i haven't seen too many
comments but my output that i believe in
so much you know i i do believe that
quantity is very underrated in social
media that content um is down um on the
flip side me and my team are really
really pushing the envelope to try to
make every post have more oomph um and
so
you know trying to figure out how to
balance the content output that really
brings me a lot of joy you know i think
for me i i've realized in the last three
or four years that speaking and the gary
vee thing
has a lot more to do with the legacy the
dms of like i mean the post i posted on
the wait here
guy comes up to me at the secret wine
party at the super bowl and tells me
like you got me out of debt like if you
watch that clip i'm 41 years old nobody
believed me and i bought nfc you got me
out of jail thank you man i'm really
proud of you thank you i love you you
got yourself out there you got
that is a 40 year old man who clearly
had a lot of weight on his chest for 20
years and like four pieces of content
changed the outcome of his life that's a
high yeah i think that's where you get
your energy 100 i can't replicate that
of like a good nft flip or yeah yeah
landing a 10 million account and so
um just balancing that okay and at this
stage in your life like what are you
still learning what do you feel like
you've mastered and what do you feel
like you're still learning
um what am i i'm still learning about
myself you know in the new book i talk
about candor i mean it took me
you know what's crazy for people
watching this is gary v
biggest strength this candor but i'm not
talking to anybody i'm talking to the
world and thus i'm not hurting dustin's
feeling or johnny's feelings or susan's
feelings
as an operator for 20 plus years
i did everything i could
to fix a situation without telling
somebody they stunk are you conflict
avoidant
yes
i'm
but what made me build big businesses
was not at 1201
okay got it yeah at 11 59 i was yes at
1201 i wasn't i would always do the
thing that the business needed you had
to get you got it done but it was so
cute it was so and what i learned and
why i wrote about it was it was so
sloppy from 10 30 p.m to 12 o'clock and
the angst and then and so what would
happen is you know really how it started
was i was reading a facebook group of
former employees and there was enough
people in there that were not loving me
and i kind of just look read it and
looked at and i was like this is a
problem it's time i fix this i know who
i am i have no ill will i only have deep
love for my employees i don't value the
money enough to be why am i in this
situation where these people don't feel
great towards me and they've worked for
me it's one thing when like
johnnypants47 leaves a comment says
you're full of [ __ ] yeah yeah that means
nothing you're like shut up yeah in the
same way that somebody says you're the
goat and they don't know you you can't
go high or low if you don't know
somebody but when i'm reading somebody
who worked for me for 19 months and i
feel like i had interactions with them
and i know how i run vayner and they're
like [ __ ] gary i'm like [ __ ] and when i
kind of really dissected it all of the
people that were not pumped all had
sloppy exits whether
we
slash i
got them to quit
through them
or they were pushed out
on thursday i would see them in the hall
and be like karen keep rocking it and on
monday we're like you got to go
and like that
was a real shortcoming and so i talk a
lot about it and i talk about how i put
the word kind in front of candor and it
shifted everything for me three four
years ago i just i just can deal with it
more i can deliver it more um
and
and i practice it more and
and it's made substantial i mean vaynerx
revenue
business the p l is dramatically
stronger today because its ceo got
better at candy yeah it trickled down
my greatest belief is that a leader's
number one goal is to eliminate fear
hence why it was hard for me to say
sally you know you're really not doing
well and we're going to need to get this
better my thought was sally leaves my
office goes and gets upset johnny johnny
leaves my office goes and gets upset
gets scared goes on linkedin and starts
up there shit's all over yeah like i
feel like candor leads to fear
and that's how i saw it for a long time
and that's wrong
but but the reason i don't call it
candor in the book and call it kind
candor is what i know for fact is over
the last 25 years i've witnessed
unlimited inside of my companies or the
hundreds of companies i've invested in
that people use candor as an excuse to
be mean
managers and bosses use well i'm just
helping you but they [ __ ] all over you
their bedside manners are atrocious and
even though they're helping you you
leave
you know stunned demotivated shook and
you're out the door and i think it's
time once and for all that we talk about
what it is
to
be a leader and build a big business and
i don't think nice guys finish last and
i don't believe you need sharp elbows
and i don't think it's you got to be
nasty i have no idea why anybody would
verbally dress down an employee in a
conference room with other employees in
there there's no logical [ __ ] sense
whatsoever to ever do i think what's
hard
about soft skills is that soft skills
require you to not only think about the
person but also manage your own ego in
the process like when you think about
this number 11 humility is impossible
one of the one of the great things for
everybody's watching because we're
talking a little bit about management
right now but this is written for
entrepreneur employee one of the
scenarios in this book is you and your
friend are both in the same department
you are best friends and they get the
promotion and you don't
that has ruined a lot of great
friendships why both of you are going to
move on to different companies anyway
why would you burn a brick the same
person yeah it's like at 24 when sally
gets in not you but you've been awesome
friends since college for two years
because you met at the office a year in
your living this is all stuff that i'm
sure resonates very well with in here
yeah because our companies have had
similar paths
like like you don't have the humility to
be first of all i talk about something
very important a human being made a
subjective opinion that sally's slightly
better than you which doesn't mean it's
true right
so why are we like don't get your
feelings caught up this is why i hate
school school trains people
to
believe in subjective opinions sure as
as every 90 days and just become a
[ __ ] robot you just like play within
a system and we like lose sight of the
bigger stuff so humility is a huge one a
huge one uh for content producers that
are watching
one of the reasons i always talk about
don't give a [ __ ] about the comments
it's not actually because of the hate
people think most of me talking about
that is about the trolls the hate the
negativity i actually think the
positivity is actually more dangerous
once you get high on your own supply
it's over you've become really
vulnerable and so for me at this point
in my career
because i do have a lot of love
coming my way you know i'm so glad i
trained myself to not hear it one way or
the other because it keeps you humble
and grounded
and keeps you curious you know curiosity
i think is a massive thing for success
well when if you think you're the goat
you don't think you have to put in the
work to be curious you know
instagram goats are not putting in the
work for web three and are gonna get
passed by you know many instagram goats
didn't listen to me when i talked about
tick tock and let it go by like
lack of humility and curiosity will keep
you stuck in your spot forever yeah
that's right i also think caring is a
big piece of it like we had someone
pretty senior leave
last week and the person did not say
goodbye to anyone in their peer group
which were they upset
that's what i'm trying to figure out
like that's a pretty big statement the
the i don't know what is it i don't even
know if an irish sex is like a bad like
term
i don't know what the current
politically correct statement is
yeah i'm good with that right but
whatever that is why would irish people
leave early though
no idea we're not playing what's that
about them all i know is let's just call
it a garyvee exit because i've lived in
my whole life i did it this weekend at
nba all-star i like to just snap out the
back just left yeah just have no
interest in the goodbye and so um
yeah maybe maybe that's the corporate
version of that like i'm pretty empty
you know i don't want to sit on this
couch and be a hypocrite i feel like i
don't think that would be the way i
would roll in that environment but um i
definitely think that people
sometimes just
you know like we're done yeah i'm done
and you may hear from that person in a
month later yeah no and that's the thing
and that's the thing i'm very big on
this the lack of
i think
having the ability not to judge
might be the greatest gift of all time
you know like when you just told me that
my brain immediately went into
what's going on with them yep right it's
never about you and that's where if like
people ever figure that out
then you can have a really happy society
people completely believe that other
people's actions have something to do
with them
it doesn't it's like i call it like the
eighth grade zit rule okay so in eighth
grade when you got a zit you were like
so [ __ ] petrified to go to school
yeah everybody's gonna see it
you're trying every product
imaginable i went through puberty pretty
late and got all my zits in like college
and which would really [ __ ] suck but
but like it wasn't too bad but like i
was good in high school but like i know
that feeling
and
my point to everybody is
everybody's worried about their zit yeah
like when you come to school nobody
cares about yourself they are [ __ ]
you they're worried about theirs yeah
and the person that actually would pick
on you for that they're in the worst
spot because they're so insecure
that they're gonna attack you first
before you get to that sure they're
going to deflect off them and i think i
think i think look i think
grown-ups just still play in high school
yeah yeah like i think we're in a place
where like all the same [ __ ] keeps
playing out and i think a lot of what i
wanted to talk about in this book was
let's reframe [ __ ] because we can yep
one quick question for you on this is
how what's your advice to people for how
they train themselves right because a
lot of what you're talking about is
self-control humility
um
living by your values
thinking having at like talk about how
you train yourself to have better soft
skills
that's a great question um
i think hence why i wrote this i think
it starts first with self-awareness i i
think everybody has to look in the
mirror and genuinely challenge
themselves and say
what am i what am i hiding what am i
full of [ __ ] about the only way you can
fix things is acknowledging them there's
no shot that you're going to fix it if
you're still in the delusion that you
don't have a problem correct yep i
subconsciously knew the candor thing was
[ __ ] up
you knew forever forever
you knew in the 10 30 to 1201 block how
much that sucked you knew it sucked yes
it would happen infrequently enough that
then you could avoid it that's right and
and it was a lack of accountability
which is my biggest strength in business
but of course because it's my half this
is where i wasn't accountable i'm like
susan should have known she sucked
it was very obvious
not get it yeah [ __ ] ricky like yeah
like come on right and it was also a
level of ego i would care about them so
much because i go very family with
employees pretty fast like i thought
well they'll be better with me
ricky stinks so he might as well work
here because he's definitely not going
to do well out there yeah
so there's a level of ego in there so i
can save ricky oh my god you know the
whole like the whole meme of like the
girl that tries to fix the bad boy yeah
oh my god i would have been the worst
girl like i would have tried to fix
every i would that would be you would
have that would have been my job i would
that's the only dudes i would have dated
especially five o'clock shadow like guys
i would be dead yeah so anyway
i
i that man is irresistible i
really think that it comes down the
answer to your question is
accountability and self-reflection and
truly challenging yourself to have the
combo the reason gratitude is number one
is the whole thing starts with gratitude
if
if the anybody who lives in a first
world country
should really take a step back and
understand that there's 850 million
people 850 million people three times
almost three times the size of america
right now as we sit and film this there
are 850 million people that do not have
access to clean water
like what you're complaining that you
didn't go viral on tick tock this month
like you're upset that you're like that
like your uber's five minutes late or
you don't have wi-fi on united on the
way back like like we just aren't
grateful
we're we're uh we're we're not grateful
yeah switching gears a little bit for
this audience talk about
3. so a lot of you
in your 20s 30s and 40s don't realize
that you just became your parents by
dismissing nfts
the same way you're [ __ ] on nfts is
the same way that your parents [ __ ] on
social media and [ __ ] on cell phones
[ __ ] on the internet and like it's a
cold shower for a lot of people to hear
that
like
here's what here's the point web3
is
means a lot of things but the thing that
we're all focusing on right now is the
consumer
blockchain the blockchain is confusing
to people because people bring their
internet brain to the blockchain the
blockchain is different than the
internet
it's decentralized servers versus
centralized servers there's a lot it
allows for ownership the internet
doesn't the joke of well i'm going to
right click right click and save it well
i could take a photo with that dog in
here and make pretend it's mine like
people oh by the way
web to social media people make way more
pretend of owning something than on web3
sure you cause on web3 i can look up if
your
nft and your bio is something you own in
web 3 in web 2 social media the guys
that go out on a thursday night in vegas
or la stand next to an expensive car and
try to claim it their own is much higher
than people talk about fake watches fake
handbags like
there's a lot of it's almost like web 3
is the antidote to
it a hundred percent web tip yet
everyone's making the hot take joke that
you can right click and save which is
the ironic part of the whole thing
humans talk a lot we write a lot we we
do a lot of things but the number one
way that human beings communicate is
through the things they buy
it is the number one thing the entire
globally globally the entire fashion
industry would not exist if people
didn't need to communicate through their
purchases
once people understand that truth why
somebody buys a
benz why all of us are literally wearing
the clothes we're wearing right now the
haircuts we have the facial hair like
all of it
we need to communicate nfts are going to
create the biggest economic
reality of our need to communicate the
reason kids want fortnite skins is to
flex in their world their world
is fortnite why does somebody want a
blue check why do people come here and
say hey
in the instagram world that's a digital
thing yeah you don't own that
you don't even own that you're renting
that from instagram but why do you want
it
why do you want a million followers why
do you want it we're living in a digital
world and the next step of that is
ownership but right now everyone's focus
is on the collectibility in the art part
with a hint of utility
what's going to happen over the next
decade is it's going to be utility
that's where you'll see the blockchain
really shine it will be utility with a
hint
of collectibility okay so give give an
example of that
you buy a louis vuitton bag
and uh they give you a receipt but it's
an nft that's a utility you've got to
get a receipt
but that piece of art was done by a
young female artist that seven years
later got famous and now your receipt is
worth eight thousand dollars and you
sell it
that's taking a mundane piece of paper
throwing garbage madison square garden
not too far from here
six years from now you go to the game
it's not a qr code it's an nft the nft
read it it's a collectible that night
the
brawny drops 90 points in the garden and
everybody goes crazy
now that becomes a collectible yes
you're leaving
and you're getting offers for 400
for that nft because it's a collectible
but it was a utility got you into the
place your triple bracelet at coachella
it's an nft six years later people are
collecting the so there's a hint of
collectibility but it was utility and
the reason that's going to happen is for
coachella instead of [ __ ] bracelets
an nft with some design on it
and then you sell it for 800 bucks
yeah they're getting 10 royalties
everybody's getting into the record
business everybody's getting into
the publishing business and it's going
to affect everything music no longer are
you going to sign with a record label
you're going to sell at nft to get 20 of
the royalties of your new project now
your friends are making a piece of the
money from spotify not the label it's
it's going to change the world and
everybody is underestimating but this is
what i love about being an owner of an
nft project you can make it valuable for
your audience you're the central bank
sure
every everybody sees people with
audiences come in and they they get
worried is it going to be bad it should
be good if the person has good intent
gary fee you're [ __ ] genius i love
you
you're just inspiring me all right five
questions let's do it
first 30 minutes of your morning
pretty pretty mundane in the first 30
minutes i'm doing like you know shower
poopy you know brush my teeth shower
[ __ ] shave you're not shaving i don't
shave often but like yes coffee yes i
like coffee kind of just makes me feel
like the day is starting grabbing your
phone not grabbing your phone immediate
grab phone i know a lot of people are
doing the whole progressive thing for
you not for me i need to i'm a
firefighter i have offices in singapore
london yeah you know like i have to make
sure nothing is burning down yeah i
don't have that luxury yep that's and
you also love it you love what you i do
love it but that's the but honestly it's
not the best part of the job like this
is where i'm in love with the number two
or the number three or the number four
for a lot of unless you have the stomach
to be a number one it's not exciting to
wake up and be like what are the
problems yeah all i do is like what are
the problems that you're like that's
what i my day is like all right what's
something you do everything that was a
fire hose not a gun everybody else i
don't know it depends on who you ask but
um what's something you do every day
without fail every day i have a moment
where i just say thank you that nobody i
love died
every day every day
it really works for me it's the ultimate
version of gratitude i'm just grateful
that the people i love were still with
me today yep it's big for me
um do you make any time to do the yard
sale thing anymore oh yeah i'm like
literally like literally was a little
warm in new york the last couple yeah
that's amazing i'm like
it's coming like
trash talk
is
very important to me because when i talk
about nfts or i talk about investing in
startups or i talk about the stuff we
talked about here
many people dm me and say things like
gary i only have ninety dollars so i'm
not buying [ __ ] and so that kept
building kept building and i'm like you
know what i'm gonna start making content
of what i did when i had ninety dollars
in high school and college when i had no
[ __ ] money at all and i wanted it i
garage sale and i didn't even have ebay
yet like i used to buy this [ __ ] and
sell it at flea markets that was [ __ ]
hard when my brother was a kid 11 years
younger than me and we started doing it
we had ebay and that was insane early
ebay you got really paid in garage sale
um
and it's been it's it's probably the
thing i'm most excited about the amount
of people that hit me up and say hey i
made eight thousand dollars this summer
and you're so fired up it's like your
victory
and it's emotional stuff hey i'm 8 000
i paid down some credit cards yeah and
i'm taking my kids to disney world this
christmas yeah like that's some like
tear [ __ ] yeah absolutely it feels nice
on instead of like sleeping in on a
saturday i think that you are such a
hunter when i think about you i think
you're such a hunter you're just a
hunter and then but you also have this
rare gift where you're not just out for
you like you're sharing your hunting
which i think is so generous
it's something i'm very you know thank
you i think that's right and it's again
back to humility it's like i got the
luck of the draw of great parenting
circumstance and dna but yeah i don't i
want everybody who allocates any time to
consuming me to win too yeah that's
right why wouldn't i yeah absolutely
um what gives you hope right now
people give me hope i think human beings
are massively underrated i'm very in
tune and aware that everyone's super hot
on saying how much we suck right now i
see it the complete other way
i think that people are grossly
underestimated every day there are
trillions of people doing wonderful
things for other people and uh human
beings give me tremendous hope we are
infatuated with nitpicking what somebody
else is doing poorly we've become in
love with pointing fingers we love
slinging shame and it's really
unfortunate because most people are
really coming from a good place and uh
and i hope we
get to a different
energy around this issue um what's a
business you're investing in now besides
nfts
nft infrastructure i'm full i'm pot
committed you're all in i'm pop
committed web 3. you know i don't play
poker but i'm dangerous enough to know
that i don't know this but i know real
poker players can look at the board and
know they have the best hand the nuts
right that's how that's how i'm playing
web three this is the best
this is here
i need to learn here's the thing even if
all of the bets lose i need to learn
everything yeah because the entire world
is going it's tuition yeah that's
awesome all right garyvee thanks for
doing this i appreciate you so much
congratulations
you